thank you
[Music]
now this is just something I noticed
when I was uh
I don't know if you guys see this on the
comments of literally anything you look
at
um people are either so Pro China or
against China or there's always a bunch
of China China right somebody acts like
they like China oh now we all have to
hate this person now we all have to love
this person you know I get it what I
don't get is how so many people don't
realize how many companies are owned by
China that are completely American like
Ford like we're about to go through six
of them that I found really really
interesting six American companies that
you wouldn't believe is owned by China
well my mind number four will you away
and they don't believe taiwan's a
country this is the first one
um AMC AMC oh yeah I knew that one yeah
because uh
that AMC down the street we heard like
that was purchased by a Chinese
billionaire but this was years ago like
pre-pandemic five years or something
yeah yeah that's a that's a crazy one
they made it if you're against China
don't ever put your butt in an amcc seat
you got Regal Cinemas we're all good to
go I think it's gonna make your American
Life pretty difficult if you don't want
to associate with anything Chinese
related in this everything is China
people really have to realize that's
really [ __ ] different use Amazon dude
everything's main trying to do
everything is here's number two General
Motors GM the
All-American GM and don't you love that
we bailed them out in 2008 and then just
to sell to China but GM isn't that like
GM Ford uh foreign
so I got a Chinese truck huh so the
company itself GM is not owned by a
Chinese company but it does rely with
its on its partnership with Shanghai
Automotive to stay profitable whoa So
you you're not really sticking it to
China or anybody by like buying them
isn't that funny how like people here
just like I'm gonna get a good
All-American truck but then a lot of the
American Vehicles now are assembled in
Mexico the parts are made in different
parts yeah it's like foreign cars are
more American the most American Truck is
a Toyota Tundra because it's made here
well and then that's because foreign
cars there's laws of foreign um like
German or Japanese there's laws of how
much they have to be assembled or or
like built in the states so that because
of those regulations there's more
domestic like work being done by Foreign
companies than our companies aren't
Fords assembled in Mexico mostly yeah a
lot of the American cars are assembled
in Mexico North America North America
that's cool here's another one that I
really didn't know Spotify what does Joe
Rogan talk [ __ ] on China I haven't heard
into it have you he does actually he
talks [ __ ] about everybody but he
doesn't say in like a malicious way just
thinks he just doesn't agree with some
of the practices and stuff interesting I
thought Spotify was like a Scandinavian
company that was a big tech company you
know that you know the Chinese group 10
cent yeah they own 10 of Spotify oh it's
temper okay so they're shareholders not
controlling interest but enough enough
for someone who's highly against China
to have to delete their Spotify if
you're a American tarian like a
vegetarian right like America if you're
a vegetarian right you eat salad someone
puts Bacon fat on it you're no longer
eating it right if you're American
10 of Spotify is a lot of bacon American
or Chinese fat on your [ __ ] salad or
you should teach children
because it's always so easy to follow
everything you're saying so in this deal
in this deal 10 cent bought 10 of
Spotify Spotify bought 10 of 10 because
the whole like purpose of that was that
Spotify wanted to be successful in China
and they were having trouble breaking in
the market so they formed that
partnership yeah it makes 10 cents
just as a little reminder to everybody
that hates when things are being sold to
China China can't buy anything that's
not being sold to them so
two-person deal oh yeah so we as in the
Americans own things in China as well
then everybody owns something somewhere
in China they can be seized by the
government at any minute that's the
difference exactly the difference is
that is it really and over here you can
get bailed out any minute but people do
who don't understand there are a lot of
people who don't understand markets
though and just Commerce like that so
they're just like well this is a scam
because you're gonna sell it to somebody
else it's like yeah well they're gonna
buy it
[ __ ] wild uh number four is Snapchat
oh that's very Chinese yeah damn they're
dominating social media huh and tick
tock tick tock's all theirs isn't it
maybe it's like a U.S uh owned Tick-Tock
version but it started with billion so
that means it definitely has some sort
of like oh they're in charge of it I
think so Facebook wasn't Trump trying to
ban Tick Tock for a minute yeah I tried
Facebook did offer to buy Snapchat for
four billion but they opted out instead
10 said Holdings again about 14 of
Snapchat shares wow yeah who still uses
Snapchat you guys on Snapchat we're all
under an agreement to act like no one
uses it so we can keep using it
secretly exactly is that the way you sly
guy isn't that not the silent [ __ ]
you're such a sexy guy they should have
sold bro that's that's what I thought
whenever guys are like who uses that
anymore and they shift their eyes
got it you do you dirty dog you used it
to jerk off that's what that means
that's all I do dude here's another one
Hilton Hotels not Paris Hilton's brand
don't tell me it's 10 cent again it's
not it's a h a group Chinese Aviation
and shipping giant they bought 25 of it
for 6.5 billion that's a good percentage
and two of the Chinese directors are on
Hilton's Board of 10 directors yeah wow
but they have been trying to sell their
share for the past two years no buyers
wow they're probably eating money huh
all these Ballers just doing the
[ __ ] and now for number six which
was the craziest thing Tabasco
actually sorry sorry let's get our
guesses in what am I doing what category
is it is it food and beverage let's just
say it's a very very general account
there's March's name objects I don't
know yep no oh you're trying to do a
Kaiser Soze honest what's uh what's up
it's General it's a very very general
thing so don't say Tempur-Pedic
because he'll throw his mattress away
dude
Sleep Number you think it's Sleep Number
okay is it a household name
yes absolutely Johnson and Johnson oh
[ __ ] Kirkland would be so crazy that's
not the one on the list but I wouldn't
be surprised if it was uh Fox is
another thing I wouldn't be surprised
the American flag making company that's
made in generation
Betsy Ross Federal Reserve oh no I don't
know if that would be public info but is
it media it's not media is it Walmart me
telling you guys it's a very general
thing is a huge hint so the word oh
General Electric General Mills no
General Electric General Electric but
only the appliance division so the
washing machines anything that GE makes
as an appliance yeah they do that
through China China and Mr higher you
know higher h-a-i-e-r sometimes yeah
they're making season stuff they bought
the company's Appliance division the
whole division 5.4 billion wow yeah so
who owns Sears though I think it's a bad
sad people shut assault to China Century
21 on Saturday
but the products they still make them in
America the ideas are generated in China
which is interesting now huh I D well
they they don't they give the ideas to
General Electric but the reason it's
such a different thing is because GE has
been around since 1892. holy [ __ ]
probably the old one of the oldest
companies that has like Chinese
ownership yeah it's pretty trippy so I
think it kind of like if you're going to
be a person like you said was it
American
dude it's really freaking difficult how
can you do that anymore even if you're
an
anti-chinesegetitarian like that's super
aren't iPhones made over there yeah
everything yeah the thing you're using
what about Samsung everything we buy on
Amazon is in China too I mean in terms
of like the infrastructure of like Crea
of what's it called textiles or
manufacturing yeah manufacturing all in
China right you rely on them too much
you would have to do all domestic stuff
would you be really expensive hard
working get a handmade computer in
America what do you want a handmade
computer for because I'm an American
Terry and I ain't trying to get no
Chinese hands on my [ __ ] I don't know if
it needs to be handmade for it to be
American so you can go to antique
roadshow in a couple years and go like
and they're like oh this is handmade
yeah wow
Susan B Anthony original one from a good
old Silicon Valley which IBM an American
company originally who owns Panda
Express I think it's American
technically American Chinese owned by
SanSai Grill yeah yum brand what are the
chances because it's a Chinese dude but
I think it's Chinese American Panda
Restaurant Group what I don't know if
this is a Chinese person whose name's
Andrew chern his father's Ming Tsai
charm hey yeah they're eight they're
Pasadena Originals let me tell you that
buddy
first tour guide I used to train
somebody that was from the family ah
he's been churning that dough I've been
turning that [ __ ] Panda ever since
who else do they own so you profited off
of it
I'm the group well have you ever had
panda in no I've seen it you know about
that on orangethorp it's like a high
quality [ __ ] yeah it's like The Gourmet
version of Panda Express like a sit down
restaurant is it really good that one
they got a few of them I don't know if
there's a rosemary one have you been
yeah love it is it good it's very it's
actually quite good because
a lot of the same stuff but just higher
quality oh okay yeah so the orange
chickens look better yeah it's better
yeah it's good I used to have it you
guys have one at CityWalk at Universal
that's right yeah so uh if you're an
American leave a little in the comments
and let us know if anybody out there has
successfully been able to avoid
everything Chinese I would like to know
how
[Music]
foreign